i'm not threatening anybody i'm not
oh
did something just happen
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today i'm joined by bobby lee thank you
so much you can catch him on the
stand-up stage yes the tiger belly
podcast yes and today we're gonna have
some wings i'm also on love
you're in love
no the netflix show love oh and he's
also on love on netflix i have a couple
of scenes there you go thank you how are
you with hot food well my ethnicity says
that i'm good at with it but um i might
i get diarrhea a lot but i don't i don't
know why i just said that but i do i
actually have a couple questions about
pooping okay cool can i say something go
ahead i like your jean-luc picard look
thank you can you say make it song make
it so i love it i love it just like the
[ __ ] people we swear yes just like
the [ __ ] tv show there we go you
ready man i love you i love you too
all right so the first one is sriracha i
pee
[Music]
i sriracha how you make eye contact
very good i want to start by taking it
all the way back to your high school
wrestling career
because it seems like an interesting
time in your life how were you as a
wrestler were you a good wrestler
wrestler let me tell you something right
now um i
got sober when i was in high school
and i was addicted to um
methamphetamines right in high school
and you did it before tournament yeah
lsd i dropped acid before tournament and
i won
and when i was on top of the guys i used
to whisper your body feels so good
because it did it felt really weird you
know
and then on meth i won because i had to
drop weight so i was pretty much a
champion so that's amazing that's i was
going to ask if that was true if you
dropped lsd before a high school
wrestling tournament and ended up
winning the wrestling tournament yeah i
imagine if i was sober i could have been
champion of the world
[Music]
this one is tapatio that's not how they
pronounce that how do they pronounce it
wow
[Music]
from the outside looking in being on a
show like mad tv or snl i'm a i'm pudgy
guy you know and i never got girls
the whole reason why i did comedy is to
get girls
and to make some money but um before i
was 24
nothing
maybe some prostitutes but nothing else
but you know what girls seem to like
comedians
and i don't want you to take this the
wrong way but you seem to do all right
for yourself you seem to play up a
couple i'm killing it now
[ __ ] murder but if i wasn't in show
business my wife would be four foot
seven her name would be ting tang
okay have you met ting ting and she
comes out i know you know whatever right
but now that i have a little bit of a
heat i can get girls that are above five
five
they have both breasts
and some sometimes a vagina
hey um jean-luc um how do i know that
your's not doctored because i started a
movie once where you know the glasses
and then it's like i drink i die and
then you're alive so bobby if you wanted
to switch if you wanted to switch you
know what if you wanted to switch wings
i'd be okay with any of that
what you don't know is that before i
even did this i looked inside your eyes
you're pretty good dude thanks man
speaking of your tenure at mad tv you
have two incredible stories
about taking dumps
once live on tv and another time in an
executive producer's office okay i'm
gonna finally say the truth about the
executive producer's office i want to
know the truth about the executive
producers okay so what happened was this
is that
i was always known as kind of a
prankster you know and um also i don't
really work i've never had a real job
job you know i waited tables and stuff
but nothing real you know i don't know
how to behave in a workplace but anyway
um
one day ike berenholtz and nicole parker
were writing a sketch in the executive
producer's office i walk in and then ike
as a joke he had tums on the table you
know for the belly and i just kind of
pulled it up hey bobby stick these in
your butthole
and of course i said yes you know
because you know it's improv right you
say yes
and i took about two
and pulled my pants down and i stuck
them inside my bow hole
have you ever put tom tom's thumbs in
your butthole no it would be the worst
for me i'll tell you what happens yeah
let me know it foams like a rabbit dog
so you you have the hole and it's just
sizzling chemical reaction right and
then what happened and then now
i can nicole are just on dying laughing
because i'm done over at this time
and then i
shot the tums the smaller ones because
it dissolved halfway out of my butt but
then after that three pieces of poop
came out after that
right so you had the two-toned and the
little piece of and that right there
destroyed the great country but then
dick plasucci
my executive producer walked in right
when that happened
and he was very angry
this one is going to ask you a question
sure
what was um jean-luc picard's favorite
beverage
was it
sprite
they didn't have sprite
i'm not up on like my star trek trivia
man okay this is a part in the show it's
kind of become a staple of the show when
people have bizarre and interesting
instagram feeds like you do we like to
do kind of a deep dive pull out some
interesting ones and ask for more
context so if you don't mind i'd like to
whip out my laptop and go through some
of your instagram pics is that cool
that's wonderful
oh sorry
you and richard simmons is that who that
is what's going on here i'm a huge fan
like i grew up with him
so i um i asked for that photo and he
was very nice and soft and gentle with
me like your eyes did he just hit you
with this pose or did you coordinate
that well i go
standing back on me and then he put his
leg up and so then i just kind of did
that what's going on and this one
that's my girlfriend that's you and it
looks like you're in a makeshift bowl of
fruit loops that's not makeshif that's
really a bowl of froot loops
yeah i met her on tinder really yeah i
swear i swipe right she swipe right when
you matched on tinder do you remember
what you opened with because that's
always oh yeah i always open you know
what i did so you do a profile picture
um of uh you like on set i told them
right it's the move right and then it's
like my opening line on the message
board is always like
am i doing it right and then i do three
of them at like i sent three by accident
like am i doing that
right right right and then you pretend
you don't know what's going on like
you've never been on it before and they
make it it's cute right this guy's
confused no i do that every time hey
look at this one yeah that's me and
larry david when i did um curb you
enthusiasm
larry david he's the hero of yours isn't
he when i met dave larry david and
worked with him that week it probably
was the greatest week of my life you
know because it's like rarely do you do
things that you want to be on right
every once in a while you'll do
something you go oh i want to be on this
right now with some of it you don't like
you know like this show for example
maybe i didn't say that
i didn't say that
my face is burning a little up and
sweating but it's fine
it's fine
now that everyone's kind of a foodie
there seems like there's this ground
swell of white people who pretend like
they know everything about asian cuisine
i wonder because la seems like the
hottest of hotbeds for that kind of
behavior yeah have you noticed that in
the wild no what i get a lot is like
i'll have comedians come into town right
and call me and go take me to korean
barbecue
right and it's like first of all how
dare you like i eat burritos too right
right and i like um white people food
like caesar salads and
croutons and stuff you guys love that
stuff yeah mayonnaise
i had to fart again i'm so sorry
let it go man
okay that was like kind of loud
how you doing okay you poop on a lot of
shows no no no no no no no no no this is
a different thing
oh yeah
i won't [ __ ] my pants
promise i promise you won't at least
give me a 30 seconds heads up okay okay
you're in eminem's video we made you and
there are a lot of moving parts in that
one you have dr dre on set you have the
lisa and cameo costume changes left and
right yeah the reason why i got that was
i was i swear to god i was at sukbuji
which is a korean restaurant on eighth
street
i was sitting there with my girl i met
my girlfriend now
a different girl before
and this korean dude next to me go hey
dude i go what's up because i'm a big
fan dude
i could thank you and he goes i direct
i go who gives a [ __ ] right like that's
everybody right yeah this time no dude
i'm real
like i know you're real
this is [ __ ] crazy this one
just hops off
and you go
give me your name i give them mine i
don't know why i did
the next thing i know i'm in a trailer
with dr dre and eminem
i actually like it
i saw it
so did you talk to eminem yeah i talked
to him i was there
what kind of questions yeah i talked to
him what do you mean what did you guys
talk
because my kids love you
because my kids love you and i go
you have kids i didn't know you had kids
and then he was cool we took up some
photos
a couple days we've done some dancing i
played an eskimo well
he was dancing with sarah palin
look-alike lisa ann
is that what she is
what is that that's her name what is she
she's a porn star
[Music]
i gotta quit watching that stuff man
[Music]
so that was this one pain pain one
hundred percent isn't paying 100 the
last thing because it's not the hottest
one it's not
then you should be paying 70 percent i
agree with you
they got to redo this they should
packaging on that because they don't
have the ceiling they don't have the
ceiling on hot sauces but you don't have
the hottest one do you
i mean do you really want to go hotter
bobby
like many comedians your origin story
has some lowly beginnings the first
chapter is kind of rough
can you describe the most desperate
living situation you ever had early on
in your career i was living in silver
lake
with eight guys sometimes we men from
jack guys would spend the night and we
they called it the dumpster
and we we lived with a 50 year old
homeless man named dave he was like a
gypsy hippie guy and then we also had a
16 year old runaway girl named sophie
wow yeah it was crazy and um
she was on the bath
quite the scene in this apartment so
like put that picture right there four
in the morn
why is it there in the first place then
i don't know
at four in the morning you would hear
like
sophie clean the house with a little
toothpaste a toothbrush
if you ever are poor you gotta get a
meth addict in your house they cleaned
the [ __ ] out of they cleaned the [ __ ]
out of it
[Music]
and my um my roommate kalisto
ready to move on
no
wanna chill
are you still with us
can i take this hat
yeah you can do whatever you want man
[Music]
because wow with hair like that i don't
know why you were even wearing a hat in
the first place
that is majestic
you're kind of the short shorts god and
short shorts are really coming back if
you go into a club monaco or something
right now short shorts are in and you've
been riding that trend all the way
through sometimes you'll just wear
briefs so i'm going to show you some
short short icons and i want you to
react to them i want you to rank them i
want you to say what you like about
their shirts
what you don't like about their short
see i'm short style
say this sure i'm going to take a bite
and that's it yeah dude i think i [ __ ]
up i went around i took a little bit
more meat that i was supposed to eat got
cocky
how about andre agassi with the denim
short short look because i hate those
you don't like these no because it's
like they're kind of like board shorts
and
um
i want to see
his body what do you think how about
this bill clinton al gore those are the
best ones i've ever seen iconic they
look like vaginas pudgy like
white legs they're so gross john
stockton he was kind of a legend of the
short shorts he has um
legs i don't ever want to see again i'm
really about to pass out okay well let's
move on let's move on before we lose you
okay
we don't want to take out bobby lee he's
a treasure did i
pass my caps
you are past mike absolutely switch the
things i don't
oh
can i just say something right now sure
i really don't want to eat this
you don't have to let's go okay
was ken jong your real actual doctor
because people might not know this but
he was a real actual doctor he was my
friend
and he was a doctor
but was he your doctor i didn't have a
doctor but he i called him for medical
stuff before he was famous
yeah
this might be the most out of bounds
follow-up we've ever had but what's like
the most invasive sort of doctor-patient
thing that he ever did to you
like do you ever perform a medical
procedure on you
um when i was going through my bike in
withdrawal
he helped me and i would say i have a
rash what is it he's like just that's
nothing what a milk is this
uh i'm lactose intolerant i'm lactose
intolerant you know can i
can i gargle it with it and then spit it
out so i don't swallow it yeah
all right might help you
i'll do it with you man
[Applause]
all right so
this one is blair's mega death sauce
with liquid rage
what's liquid rage that's a good
question i think it's just
marketing i mean what the [ __ ] is liquid
i think it's a well you're putting more
on it so what we do is we dab the last
wing you don't have to if you don't want
to bobby i feel like you've really
overextended yourself if anything so if
you just want to okay you're gonna
step up
you think i'm going through the struggle
[ __ ] do
what you're gonna [ __ ] do
you think that you wait wait you really
think that i'm saying you don't have to
but you're you're going to do it
are you going to do it if you do it i'm
going to [ __ ] do it love it bobby lee
um stop because we're not in a rush
you're not you have no one else i know
you guys have [ __ ] to do but i have to
say something to my [ __ ] agent right
now okay
[ __ ] you
you understand me yeah
you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] let's go all
right
love it bobby love it is that enough for
you love it let's do it
so i know
[Music]
this whole thing that i'm doing are
yelling at everyone i've never done that
before in my life i don't know what the
[ __ ] why i'm doing it like that it's
just coming from a dark place bobby the
hot sauce is taking it out of you but i
want you to know i am so sorry everybody
i just want to say this that i am so
sorry i'm really a nice guy and i don't
mean i'm not threatening anybody i'm not
did something just happen
yeah hold up hold on hold on hold on
hold on
ah
[Music]
no
oh did you hear it
oh it's not happening yeah i did no it
didn't it's fine
[Music]
i also don't ever want to do this again
you have the heart of a champion bobby
lee you have strength inside of you you
can go and you can find it because you
have the eye of the tiger look at you
you cleared
the board
the floor is yours we make you earn your
plug in this game but boy did you earn
it number one i have a podcast with my
girlfriend called tiger belly and we're
on um all things comedy i also number
two
i'm in a lot more of season two of love
on netflix it comes out march but [ __ ]
it you know
i like you but
i don't want to see you for a while i
think that's fair i literally [ __ ] my
pants
sulfur
tail can everyone see that